Hi, Mystery Recapped here.
Today I am going to explain a German Sci-fi
film called “Hidden reserves.”
Spoilers ahead!
Watch out and take care!
In the near future, a dystopian society comes
into existence in Vienna, Austria.
Eighty-two percent of the Viennese population
live below the poverty line and for only one
percent of the population, prosperity and
wealth continues to rise.
Since more than two third of the population
is under serious debt with no sources to pay
it, an insurance company creates a new system.
After death, the indebted citizens are reanimated
and kept in an artificial twilight state.
Their lifeless body is used for several purposes
as a compensation of the debt they had collected
throughout their life.
The dead bodies’ mental and physical resources
are used for purposes like to store spare
human body parts or to use their brains to
store information.
Most young women’s corpses are often used
as birthing machines.
Only the people who have death insurance can
avoid the fate of being used even after death.
However, the insurance is so expensive that
only a few wealthy people can afford it.
The protagonist of the movie is a man named
Vincent Baumann.
He is an insurance agent at the death insurance
field sales.
Vincent is one of the wealthy people who convinces
the other wealthy ones to get death insurance
from their company.
In the beginning of the movie, he drives to
work for an important meeting with a potential
client.
Somewhere else in the city, an old woman dies
but her family doesn’t want to hand her
body to the debt collectors.
Hence, they put her in a vacuumed plastic
body bag to ship her somewhere else.
However, their plan fails when someone informs
the soldiers about the dead woman and they
are arrested for their deeds.
They bring the woman’s body out of the bag
and quickly start the resurrection process
to keep her body in a vegetative state for
future use.
Back in the insurance company, Vincent practises
persuading the client before the meeting.
He plans to show the client the video of a
woman being recruited, alongside the video
of a normal funeral that will be provided
to the people with death insurance.
According to him, the side by side comparison
will definitely get him a deal.
Somewhere else, a girl named Lisa Sokulowa
wears a blonde wig and disguises herself as
someone else.
She is an activist who works against the current
debt collecting system along with her fellow
activists who have formed a group called the
parallel society.
Their main aim is to turn off the life support
camps where the reserved dead bodies are kept
with an attack.
But they still have a long way to go to achieve
their goal.
The men who got arrested yesterday for trying
to conduct the old woman’s funeral are also
members of their group.
Lisa and her associate Frei discuss the way
to get them out of imprisonment so they wouldn’t
tell the police about their organisation.
Frei claims that there is no way to retrieve
them without a proper ID that they do not
own.
But Lisa has connections she can talk to and
arrange the IDs in a day.
At night, she goes to a party to meet her
source named Philip who hands her a level
two identification card.
Philip is also an insurance sales worker who
sells secret information for money.
Lisa demands a level three card because the
mission requires them to gain access to the
secret offices.
Philip hesitates, but agrees to get the card
in two days.
Vincent has a unique way of persuading potential
clients.
He researches every aspect of their lives
before the meeting and uses them to convince
the clients.
This time, he has memorised an old lady’s
favourite song and her fears.
He is currently dancing with her on the said
song while telling her about the possible
risks if she doesn’t get death insurance.
His plan works and he finals the deal.
He meets his colleague Dietrich the next day
at work.
The old lady was actually Dietrich’s client
who he couldn’t persuade.
He asks Vincent to take yet another one of
his clients, Wladimir Sokulow, because he
is impossible to persuade.
Wladimir Sokulow is Lisa’s wealthy father.
Meanwhile, Lisa and the parallel community
are trying to figure out the ways they can
attack the geriatric ward where all the dead
people are kept.
They plan to destroy it and let the revived
dead bodies die in peace.
Vincent’s boss Diana Dorn and the company
board interview him for a potential promotion.
He is asked to make Lisa’s father Wladimir
get death insurance if he wants to be promoted.
When he returns to work the next morning,
he notices that his friend Dietrich has been
replaced with Philip.
Since Dietrich couldn’t make most sales,
it doesn’t surprise Vincent.
At the club, Lisa and Frei wait for Philip
to arrive with the identification cards but
he never does.
She goes to check in his house but it turns
out that after Philip was promoted, his old
apartment went to Dietrich and his wife.
Lisa and Frei believe that Philip might have
sold them out to the insurance company.
Lisa is relieved because she hadn’t told
Philip about their plan to attack the geriatric
ward.
She sees Dietrich leaving his house and follows
him to the market.
He goes to the insurance company office and
transfers his death insurance to his unborn
child.
Following that, he walks to a bridge and commits
suicide.
He has been troubled by the demotion at work
and couldn’t handle the pressure anymore.
Lisa is beyond surprised at what she witnessed.
After his death, Lisa’s father’s case
is transferred to Vincent.
Since he is a very important client, if Vincent
is unsuccessful in making the deal, he will
be demoted to a mere field representative.
Vincent takes on the challenge and gathers
all the information about Wladimir.
Naturally, he also has to learn about Lisa
to approach her father with a good deal.
He goes to meet Wladimir according to their
appointment and happens to bump into Lisa
on the way.
The two share a brief conversation before
she leaves.
Vincent knows that he has to go out of his
way to persuade Wladimir.
He has found out that Wladimir transferred
his insurance to Lisa which she is unknown
about.
And since she is so against death insurance,
she will surely give it to someone else if
she finds out.
Vincent blackmails Wladimir using this information.
But the man doesn’t budge.
Because of this Vincent loses his current
position in the job.
Diana appoints him as a field representative
with his main aim to catch the activists who
are speaking against the insurance company.
She also puts him on Lisa so that she can
persuade her father to take out a death insurance
policy.
Vincent’s current apartment is taken away
and he has to move to the satellite and container
districts that surround Vienna.
His new room is tiny and dusty, something
he is not used to.
After researching Lisa's life, he finds out
she sings in a pub and goes to see her.
They chat briefly after which, Lisa returns
to the changing room.
To her surprise, one of her friends who had
been arrested, Chris, has escaped and returned
to them.
He is heavily injured and won’t survive
without proper medical assistance.
The next day, Vincent again returns to the
club claiming that he wants to hear her sing
again.
Frei says that Vincent is their only chance
to get a level three identification so Lisa
will have to befriend him to acquire it.
Later, Lisa follows him to his apartment.
She rents a room with a clear view of his
windows and spies on him.
While she is at it, she calls him and asks
to go out on a date.
Vincent is suspicious of the sudden proposal
but since he has to use her to get to her
father, he accepts to go.
To manipulate her, he reveals that her father
has transferred his insurance to her.
The following day, Lisa meets Chris who is
on the verge of death.
He begs her to not let him go to the geriatric
ward.
Lisa quickly rushes to the insurance company
and transfers her insurance to Chirs.
He dies shortly after but the police leave
him because of the insurance.
The following day at work, Vincent is informed
that Lisa’s father Wladimir has been in
an accident and is heavily injured.
It is clear to him that the accident was the
company’s plan to take over Wladimir’s
wealth.
But he has no basis to prove the claim.
He quickly goes to meet Lisa who is devastated
by her father’s accident.
He clarifies that he wasn’t the one behind
it but she doesn’t believe him.
She doesn’t even get to see her father because,
without insurance, his body belongs to the
company.
She is dedicated to getting him out of the
geriatric ward.
At night, Vincent goes to meet her in her
apartment.
They eventually kiss and make love.
But when he is asleep, Lisa scans his wrist
and steals his third-level identification.
Her main motto for spending the night with
him was to use him to get to the ward and
free her father.
The next day, the company and Vincent find
out that she was successful in getting him
out of the geriatric ward.
Diana blames him for being careless but Vincent
had put a tracker in Lisa’s bike.
Using it, the police find her father and bring
him back to the geriatric ward.
Lisa tries to save him but Vincent stops her,
claiming that they will arrest her if she
interferes.
The next day, he goes to the pub again.
Lisa cannot help but tear up after seeing
him.
He claims that the insurance company used
him to get to her and that he had no connection
with her father’s accident.
He no longer wants to help the company and
is now on her side.
She takes him to the life support camp where
they see bodies of people being taken inside
the geriatric ward.
Vincent notices that one of the bodies is
Dietrich’s.
He is disgusted that the company is profiting
from their employee's death.
Lisa tells him that she needs a three-level
identification card to get to her father and
bring him out.
Vincent agrees to give her his card if she
promises that someone else will enter the
ward to get her father because he doesn’t
want to put Lisa’s life in danger.
Lisa then brings him to an abandoned water
park where she used to play as a kid.
She reminisces about her childhood days and
claims that the park is her favorite place
in the entire world.
That night, the two make love and share the
card’s information.
The following day, Lisa disguises herself
as an employee from the insurance company,
planning to disobey Vincent and go to the
ward herself.
She and the others from the parallel society
devise an elaborate plan to paralyze the geriatric
ward from the inside with an electromagnet.
Lisa enters the establishment without any
trouble.
Vincent finds out about this and follows her
behind.
Everything goes according to the plan but
when Lisa is about to attack, Philip unexpectedly
stops her.
It turns out that his job from the very beginning
was to find out about the parallel society’s
plan and stop it.
Outside, Frei is also arrested.
Lisa is brought to her father when Vincent
suddenly attacks the guard in an attempt to
help her.
However, before she can escape, she is shot
by Philips.
She limps towards a shocked Vincent and passes
away before his eyes.
Philips raises his gun to shoot him as well
but stops.
When Vincent opens his eyes again, Diana is
in front of him.
She says that unknowingly Vincent helped them
with the job, so he is promoted again and
is allowed to move out of the satellite town.
He then gets up and sneaks into the geriatric
ward to look for Lisa.
He finds her with the surrogate mothers, where
she is artificially kept alive to be impregnated
later.
He loosens her life-sustaining tubes and brings
her out of the ward.
Diana sees this but doesn’t stop him.
At last, he lets her drown in an old water
slide that she used to visit as a child.
Subscribe for more videos like this, turn
on the notification, and leave a like to help
the channel out.
Thanks for watching.